>>Okay, so, we're going to start
off the master chart right here,
and the narrator introduces the film.
"Ah, the Natural Selection Pet Shop."
>>Shawn: When they first come
into my classroom, I tell them,
"This is not a classroom.
You are new hires of k9 Studios, and
that's what we call our studio here."
And that their grade is
really their paycheck.
>>Narrator: Shawn Sullivan teaches
beginning through advanced animation
as part of the artworks career
pathway at Sheldon High School
in Sacramento, California.
>>Shawn: Animation is definitely an
area that covers all of academics.
To be able to create
something in the computer,
you need to understand
plotting coordinates,
so X, Y, and Z coordinates.
Also, if you're creating
characters, understanding anatomy,
muscle structure, not only
human but also looking
at animal science, as well.
Physics is very important
in animation,
making things moving believably.
>>Student: What you want to
do with the sneeze is try
to make the rodent look more round...
>>Shawn: Also, what they're
learning is what they can take
to any job they do -- working
with teams, coming up with an idea
and sharing it with others, and
seeing it being finished and created.
>>Characters: Yay!
>>Shawn: We spend a lot of hours
together, and I really focus
on the concept of being a
family and working together.
If one person is not focused and
not wanting to do this project,
it will fall apart, but if they all
believe in each other and all want
to help each other and make the
person next to them even better,
that's how you get a strong program.
>>Student: I think I found
all the sounds we need.
>>Shawn: In here, we just take
what their interests are --
I like to call it "stealth
teaching" --
and using that to teach in the
direction that they want to go in.
>>So if you're doing
up close on this shot,
you know you have to
focus on his size.
>>Shawn: The key is being honest with
your students and sharing with them
and trusting when they have an idea
and guiding them, and
they respect that.
>>Okay.
>>Juan Luis: Really,
I've been spoiled here.
Like, no other kid can say, "Oh,
I got to direct a class
making an animated film."
That's an experience that a lot of
people just really think is great.
When I went down to interview at USC,
they were really impressed by that.
>>Just a little more theatricality.
Can you call quiet on
the set real quick?
>>Hey, quiet on the set!
>>Megan: You just get a lot of work
skills from it, just being punctual,
professional, and just really
getting a feel of, all right,
do I really like this stuff?
Is this really what
I want to go into?
>>So, where's the edit at right now?
>>Megan: This really helped me decide
on what I was going to
major in in college.
>>Shawn: Doing an academy
is really important.
It gives a chance for the students
to be around like-minded students.
Already having an idea of
where they want to go to school
and what they want to do for a
living is a huge step for a teenager.
It motivates them by looking
at other people working
on the same, similar concepts.
It's a very powerful tool.
>>Do you guys need anything else
other than just the main color shots?
>>3D.
>>Megan: Deadline for this film is
this Friday, and, yeah, right now,
based on what I saw this morning, it
looks like we're going to make it.
>>Okay, cool.
Thanks, guys.
>>Megan: I'm going to
really miss this studio.
>>Narrator: For more
information about what works
in education, go to Edutopia.org.